Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Sorry, I'm just looking for my little bit of paper here.
Okay.
I just thought that September's a sort of beginning for people.
You know, academia sort of wakes up, schools go back, the summer holidays are over, and usually people about this time think about what they're going to do during the autumn and winter.
So start joining courses and hopefully going to meditation groups.
So I just thought to go over some sort of just general instructions which we all know but it's sometimes important to have it reminded to us and as I'm speaking it to you I'm actually reminding myself of the importance of what I'm saying.
So the first thing of course is good sleep and
You really have to sort of wind down at the end of the day.
I mean, you've got to give yourself half an hour.
It's no good coming off a Netflix horror film and throwing yourself into the bed or coming off social media and then expecting yourself to have a deep sleep.
Really, if you can just find that half hour before you intend to sleep, you can do anything.
You can do, you know, metta practice, meditation, read, read something which is calming, something which is inspiring, listening to music, not heavy rock, more like some spiritual music, something that's calming.
And what that does is, you know, it creates this strata underneath the sleep, a sort of...
calmness underneath the sleep and then when you're in bed to continue that to find some sort of practice either relaxing on the breath not to not to awaken the inquiry just to feel the loveliness of it the body breathing or meta you know there are all these little practices and of course it just helps us to have a deeper sleep and then uh when you wait and then in in the morning that that morning sitting
It doesn't matter how long you do it, it's the quality of it.
And often, when we've been practicing for so long, we just get very lazy, just sit there for an hour with the head going all over the place and we can tick a box.
There's not much point in it, rather for sitting 10 minutes, you know, with good intention.
So I always think it's good practice, you know, when you finally decide to sit, just to stay there for a minute and just think about the worries, concerns, the planning, the excitements that you expect during the day.
Because the Satipaṭṭhāna discourse actually begins by putting aside those things, you see.
So it's sort of recognizing what's there at the back of the mind
and and just putting them to the side it's not as though you're going to forget them
And then, of course, you have to make this clear determination that you are going to put effort into the practice.
And it's good to start with just a little bit of calming meditation.
Place the attention on the breath.
The mind is very busy.
Don't forget there are these five touch points.
So you feel your knee, then you feel the other knee, feel your hand, feel the other hand, and then come back to the breath.
And as you feel yourself settling, at one point when you get back to the breath, you could probably stay there.
and then when you feel that settlement uh you know just begin by recognizing the beginning and end of the breath and of course be open to whatever draws your attention now uh during that sit something might come up which is uh should we say pretty obvious which keeps your attention some some difficult emotion uh some pain you know some discomfort
So we can remind ourselves of the process of vipassana.
So when something unpleasant comes up, that's the easiest really, one immediately recognizes your relationship, the aversion, not wanting that at all.
And remember, this is the direct psychological cause for our suffering.
And it's a case of staying with that and sort of hanging on in there
until it completely passes.
And then you find this equanimity with what's ever being presented.
And of course, you're actually growing impatience too, being able to bear what is unpleasant.
And then you sort of distance it, right?
So there you've got this anatta, whatever you're looking at is not me, not mine.
And you can use a little word like there.
So there's a discomfort, there's some emotional turbulence.
And you create that distinction between whatever is feeling it and what is being felt, right?
And although in the literature you always get this word observing, the accent should be on feeling, actually directly experiencing what's happening.
And once that's established, it's as though you can go into it and deconstruct it, find out what it's made of.
So a pain might end up just being tightness or fiery feelings.
An emotion could just be wobbliness or a feeling of sickiness or something.
But as you go in there at that level, the quality of impermanence is a bit more obvious to you.
So just in that movement, recognizing the reaction, waiting for it to pass, distancing what it is you're looking at,
and then investigating more closely you're actually exercising this curiosity around the three characteristics of existence and that's what's going to you know liberate us
The fact that emotional turbulences are actually dying away, they're blowing out, you might say, they're being transformed into their opposite just by allowing that energy to arise and express itself, that's by the by.
So you have to be careful you don't slip into psychotherapy because it's happening quite naturally.
You don't have to work at it.
So as you progress in the sitting and your mind's wandering and all that, don't keep forcing yourself back.
Just stop for a minute and ask yourself, what is it that's making the mind wandering?
Come back in the body.
It could be that you're also coming through a time when you're feeling a bit dozy, a bit tired.
So then make that your observation.
So that you're awakening this understanding of actually feeling things and allowing this intuitive awareness to make its own understandings.
And then when you come to the end, I mean, this is what I try and get people to do is to reflect upon the hour.
And don't forget, you know, if you've really made the effort, it doesn't matter whether the mind's been wandering all over the place, it's the effort to come back and restart, restart.
And, you know, we ought to congratulate ourselves, an extra biscuit.
And if you thought, well, you could have done better, well, you have to encourage yourself.
It's no good, you know, punching yourself on the nose.
What's the point of that?
And then after that to make some resolution.
So it could be, you know, if you didn't feel you were so committed to being in the present, you know, just make that resolution.
Next time I'll really make that commitment.
And if there was a part that you felt you really were, you know, highly investigative and the mind was break, encourage yourself, right, I've got to get there next time.
And then of course after that there's metta.
So this metta is really helping that equanimity that you need for the vipassana.
So that's your not coming from an I know place or any sense of preference or anything like that.
uh and it's it's it's sort of under undermining the possibility of its corruption into its what we call the subtle enemy which is indifference aloofness it stops you sort of engaging so it's really important that the method is practiced after any vipassana sitting and uh that's the time you can bring to mind people you're going to meet during the day
And in so doing, you're sort of preparing yourself for that meeting, especially people whom you might be having some difficulties with.
Difficult.
So those two things are important.
And then, you know, make that decision to try and feel at ease during the day.
Keep coming back to just relaxing into the present moment.
and so what helps that is to keep stopping you'll see writers use the word pausing you know i prefer the word just stop just just stop and and just catch what it is that's that you're uh that you're developing sometimes unknowingly like a little irritation a little anxiety whatever's there you know a little excitement you know
and just allow it to drop keep coming back to that level of contentment because that's where you know we'll we'll find that ease with living you could always sort of headed yourself either because you're anxious about something or because you want to do something and it's just a sort of waste of energy really so if you always if we if we make that effort just to just to stop and just come back to a place of ease uh
you'll see that that it tends to um support mindfulness uh but but it also saves so much energy because you know this emotions and stuff they really draw upon our energy
And then to develop this affectionate awareness.
That's why we go through the discourse on loving-kindness at the end of this session.
Because what the Buddha is encouraging us to do is to develop an affectionate awareness.
so the awareness is of course being bright being awake to what's actually happening and the affectionate is referring to a general attitude in the heart of kindliness see so even now as as you're listening to me and as you're you're seeing me you can actually develop a nice attitude of kindliness towards me and it would make me feel so much better to know that so many people are beaming this lovely kindness towards me
i mean if you if you have that as a general attitude which you've developed as a general attitude you can see it it calms situations it it just undermines anybody who might be a little miffed with you or something like that but it's also good for us i mean it creates this lovely feeling of of of an inner gentle happiness so uh put those two words together it's not just mindfulness it's affectionate mindfulness
mindfulness with kindliness.
I mean, that's one of the things the Buddha says that we should do.
We should look at each other with kindly eyes.
And then see if you can find some time in the day to spend just five minutes, ten minutes, just being with yourself.
And then finally, when you get to the evening, coming back from work,
or a day out or whatever just to you know just to sit down somewhere and recollect the day and if you find the mind wanders a lot when you're doing that you can always write it on a bit of paper and as you go through the day you can see where you've been skillful where you could have been more skillful yeah
and that sort of uh reflection is very helpful because it slowly wakens us up to certain habits that we'd like to you know be rid of and certain habits that we'd like to develop uh you know having been brought up a catholic it was always we were always told in the evening to have an examination of conscience that's how they put it so we always thought oh my you know i better go try to get confession pretty quick
So, but I mean, it's a good thing.
You know, you just go through the day recollecting what's happened and it just makes you more aware of yourself.
That's all.
then of course uh to try and do some some sitting it doesn't matter how long you know it doesn't matter how long five minutes ten minutes uh before you eat i mean you know doing it after you eat is miserable you just fall asleep so it's okay so and then and then you've got the evening you see uh you know with more energy so um these are just sort of basic um
reminders, you know, on how to sort of go through the day gently, at ease.
I mean, that's what we, on the Metta, when we do the Metta practice, you know, it's to live more contented, you know, be more contented with what we have and in harmony, that harmony with the world, you know, whatever's happening around us.
So these are just a little pointers, you know, to, to remind ourselves.
And on top of that, it's always good to, you know, have a little bit of feed intellectually, just an occasional read, uh, from a book, a spiritual book, a Buddhist book or something, or listen to a talk.
Uh, and it's just, you know, it's just that little bit of, of encouraging ourselves to just keep, keep, uh, just keep the practice turning over.
So, um,
I hope this little talk has been of some use, that you're all eager now to sit in meditation, and that I've not actually undermined your hopes to do so.
So I can only hope, thank you very much, and that you will be liberated by your practice sooner rather than later.